[Music]
as americans buy millions of new
smartphones
so too do we throw old models into the
garbage
with the mako old messages but also all
sorts of valuable materials
used in the phones rare earth minerals
at the same time
we dutifully separate glass and paper in
our blue recycling bins
despite the fact that much of what we
put out at the curbside actually has
little
resale or reuse value and it costs our
local government
scarce funds to collect here's why
in 2017 china once the most common
destination
closed its doors to foreign recyclables
cities must pay now to have recyclables
taken off their hands and the contents
of those virtuous blue bins
often negative that's why many cities
have halted recycling
all together we need to rethink
recycling
as a sort of trash mine separate the
valuable stuff
and stop spending scarce post-pandemic
public dollars
to collect stuff we actually have to pay
to get rid of
let's get smart about recycling do you
think recycling still makes sense
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you want our scholars
to cover
in 60 seconds be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from aei